[Music]
and didn't need the lift news sending
the lift bro submitted by love from
Barbados Barbados rihana
a man's car was stolen in less than a
minute with a forklift what they picked
it up and took it away
that's ballsy my car was stolen less
than a minute
shaky no so I went to a icicles gym
called Bally's before got bought out by
LA Fitness oh yeah the one who rose mean
and one time I went to the gym and then
I went inside I went to go workout when
I come back out I was like wait with the
[ __ ] my car was parked here and it was
gone oh my did I forget my parking spot
or whatever so I went over to Target
which is next door to that gym and we
were looking at the security cameras and
then lo and behold I parked in the same
spot you see my car come in I leave in
about like 20 minutes later this guy
approaches my par like 11 18 and 11 19
that car was already backing out and
gone so he less than a minute how did he
do it so fast what do you do I had a
Honda Civics it was just super easy to
steal that's gone in 60 seconds remember
that loved that movie
so good it was Nicolas Cage doing it too
that's the cream they could do with that
fast
he probably had a G key oh he shimmies
it right shimmies the ones like that
pixelated security camera so you can't
really see what he's doing you just see
a guy approach it's almost like
stop-motion you know like those old
security footage like he approaches the
car car door opens car door closes cars
out it was like that alright back then
it wasn't a smooth it was it was times
like what do you stop-motion yeah take a
picture take a picture find it they
track the car
thanks mom yeah they found it I found my
car on the side of the freeway like I
think like a week later Joey Ryan and
then it was the doors were gone the
seats were gone all four tires were
spare tires the hood of it was gone
every just stripped down so we ended up
top chef that's what they do right chop
chop chop drop top not that's not the
song it sounded good there yeah so this
happened in Hawaii
I'm gonna show you guys the video clip
it always interests me like when you
steal a car on an island it's like where
can you go on the other you know how I
could like how they gonna not find me I
guess you got to chop it right yeah well
this one seemed like you might have been
personal the way they handled everything
cuz the four clip will [ __ ] up your car
but what they did to it after too much
you will see in this video I got scared
I felt violated that happened in a
parking lot near the kalila Airport
David tells me he went to pick up his
car on Saturday morning but it was gone
surveillance video from a nearby
building show riding on us this is
hilarious pull into the pool my god
person eventually pulls back around next
to David's car lifts it off the ground
and then rides off down the street with
all these people I was like wow I put an
alarm on it
I bought even that lock for the sting
but no matter what you do to secure your
vehicle you'll find a way to steal it
and David filed a police report and a
few hours later officers found the
vehicle here they had been stripped and
burned it really hurts it's home you
know I mean it's personal you know I
understand they steal the car but they
did it personal when they burned it he
was targeted the Honda was a project
vehicle together it's my career I work
very hard and and try to provide for my
family yes I do fall down but I try to
pick myself up there you go and when
people Charlie knocked me down again
it hurts it really hurts that's what
kind of games we got in Hawaii look at
how slow that [ __ ] was rolling dude and
no one was saying that people I mean
what do you say though like if the
person acts like they belong there and
that's that they're supposed to be doing
you're like oh he's just doing it
otherwise hella nice too like why would
you even think anything I wouldn't
question that you have a forklift
obviously yours but I would question
you are it's not a tow truck it's a
forklift dude would you be like would
you like run but I'd be like yo whose
car is that cuz that's weird it's also
Hawaii we're smart I feel like that's
weird what are we gonna get today guys
yeah that's not that's not a tow truck
though yeah you know like I don't know
cuz on one side you'll see like someone
on a paddleboard with a puppy and a
puppy's not supposed to be on the
paddleboard
either like I mind a question so you
look over and you're like okay there's a
car on the forklift it's Hawaii [ __ ] it
yeah well you see where [ __ ] I know the
island culture here what have you burn
the car well the [ __ ] of the dog paddle
board although yeah I mean yeah the fact
that the first trip the car there's
probably a murder vehicle I get why they
birthday party or nothing killed someone
or something you know get rid of
evidence
yeah you wouldn't think it's personal ah
I think no I wouldn't think it's
personal
and the car was left upside down - yeah
so somehow they tilted it over got a
bunch of Samoans and lifted it they
probably just stripped everything and
then they [ __ ] you could change the
forklifts up and down so you could go
like this and just drop it and then fell
upside down and then it burned it with
no fingerprints till so easy why that
why that car particular that car on the
toyota camry like that the two most
stolen cars in america but why is it the
the way that so for my car one of my
buddies was actually steals cars he just
showed me so when you go to the glove
compartment karma what's his name so you
got a glove compartment you can unscrew
this screw in this entire radio comes
out so he's like you're gonna steal a
radio this is so easy doesn't matter
what their heading that they have it
only takes one screw and then is
different now with the model that you
have is different these are like 98 and
97 and it was really easy with the
Flathead to just turn the car ignition
on you just stick it in your screwdriver
easy just you know where you put the key
in the ignition area you can actually
take that plastic part off and then rip
that out and then you can just turn the
wheel like that yeah
you don't do all that stuff in the movie
through your Hotwire it's just literally
I think you need to shave key or
something pens on the car there's
something called the G key to where like
you could have a master key which all
like I guess dealerships and whatever
half and then they'll make copies of
that and then you can just walk in and
just open every single like toyota
cressida or every single - like the
Honda Civic stealing cars is so bad man
thank God my car's never been stolen
I like ever been broken into that car
was broken in and stolen three times
like that's such a but oh what happened
to us with that was a micros your car
remember like it was like at least once
a month your Tahoe is getting broken
into oh yeah
why was that why was that a target
though at Tahoe I don't know the - it
was like I would just go up to my car
and then my car door would just be open
I really enjoyed what the [ __ ] what did
you have like [ __ ] gold watches on
your - pros like oh it was like bear
like you would keep nothing in there
later you sit in there you just feel
like you just like got violated your
shits all over the place like your
[ __ ] pens paper napkins whatever food
they would just come and break into
those things and I hadn't worn - but we
never like hurt it
no all my car's got broken into all of
them weren't you in advance not recently
Monterey Park oh right
but when I lived in El Monte it happened
like all the time was once a month my
friend loved going to like raves and
conventions because he would just go to
the parking lot and break into cars
pharmacy you know you know that
everyone's leaving their purses are like
the bigger stuff porn porn stuff inside
the car and I'm not like damaged so
that's why you go raving you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] man just steal cars
that's not as bad as breaking into a car
that's out of funeral because that's
robbing my mom oh that's low man that's
pretty low that's really low but that is
a perfect place because there's so many
cars so many cars we broke into your
mom's car so and criminals already don't
really have morals
yeah solar Papa not engage
one at least one like not a few well
they don't like the rain crime is lower
when it's raining that sugar or astara
sheriff buddy told us that Hawaii rains
all the time there yeah maybe it's a la
thing everyone so like wants to avoid
the rain like who it's raining I'm not
robbing today maybe he tried another
time they pulled the forklift out it
started raining is like ah [ __ ] it
really slowly hurry it's like that's
funny how slow they speak [ __ ] draw
away with it like yeah like how far away
did he take that card he put it on a
flatbed and drive off probably how far
away did he drive with that car and it's
funny cuz like no cops stopped them like
that's totally illegal you first of all
you can't even drive on the street with
the forklift roof and then they have a
car on it like you said it's Hawaii it
is Hawaiian that's happening there's
people with boom boxes duct-taped to the
front of the handlebars normal bumping
music the ten Samoans in a truck bed is
the best oh yeah cuz I miss riding on a
truck bed like they used to do that all
the time here yeah my brother would have
my dog and me in the back of the [ __ ]
truck bed my dad had died me and then
the golden retriever would be [ __ ]
all over the place that was scared and I
would be dodging the [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
sliding around in the truck bed I only
did that in Mexico I never did that yeah
yeah it was fun though I liked is it's
legal right back then I think Oh before
the seatbelt law came into play I think
yeah in the 90s back to my boy yo cuz I
remember people would have truck beds in
like small benches and then they would
have like the cover and then all the
kids could kind of like sit in the back
like the camper cover yeah yeah and it
would be like a like a bus ride yeah but
you can't do that now we don't even have
a camper dude it was just the truck bed
the rich people who had campers in our
truck beds let me get a camper but it
had a can't pronounce dodging Tyson's
dog [ __ ] the other Tyson oh no no what I
really want is a truck or a Jeep with
the machine gun on top so you could
stand up and do the
what are you trying to kill everyone
just shoo [ __ ]
[Music]